tell me a little bit about what's going
on here so mrs. giving us two for the
Hadley family there's a constant wait
for the phone to ring 14 year old Anna
has been on the heart-transplant list
for more than a year and the hospital
could call at any time but her condition
means the family is prepared after
discussing organ donation my
registration card dropped out of my
wallet and she wanted to know what it
was my wife had never really thought
about it and about becoming a donor at
that point and her initial reaction was
one that she wasn't quite sure and so we
as a family spent time convinced
convinced and that's what I wanted and
this is what she would need to do in the
case that I would potentially pass away
and now my wife is a donor registered
donor she sees the benefits and the
reasons for it and obviously in the long
run it's it's it's come full circle I
think it's extremely important for the
families to have this chat because it
makes kids more aware of what's going on
in other places and the fact that if
something were to happen to them that
they could help from next spring a new
system of organ donation will be
introduced in England
meaning adults will automatically be
donors unless they opt out it's already
in place in Wales and will also be
introduced in Scotland next year but
this only applies to adults not children
over the last five years 42 children
waiting for heart transplants have died
over a five year period there was an
average waiting time of up to a hundred
and three days for children needing an
urgent heart transplant for an adult
it's only a third of that around two and
a half thousand organs each representing
an opportunity for transplant were
missed in the last year because family
said no to donating their relatives
organs those running England's organ
donation system say however difficult
it's important parents involve their
children in conversations about organ
donation there are many children waiting
for transplants and one in four of them
are waiting for hearts and and heart you
know sadly because of the lack of donors
actually the children tend to get much
sicker and much more likely to die on
that list although children can join the
organ donor register they must have
their parents
consent for a donation to take place the
NHS says talking to children about the
issue could be a life-saving
conversation
dan whited Sky News in Worcester